we begin with the death of Charles
Manson the mastermind of a series of
notorious 1969 murders died last night
at a California hospital Manson was 83
nearly 50 years ago he led a group of
young followers called the Manson Family
he instructed them to kill seven people
their best known victim was Sharon Tate
who was pregnant at the time eight
months pregnant a young Hollywood
actress the murders and the mind of
Manson himself intrigued the public for
decades Charlie Rose sought for himself
up close it was that murder okay because
you didn't see it murder there's no
there wasn't a murder it was decried as
a monster but even during his 46 years
behind bars
Charles Manson continued to elicit a
morbid fascination by an uncomprehending
public I spoke with him in 1986 how do
you feel about those murders how do you
feel about that's what counts
happen in your world in 1971 Manson was
found guilty of conspiracy to commit
seven savage murders in Southern
California among the victims 26 year old
actress Sharon Tate who was expecting
the child of husband and acclaimed
director Roman Polanski
he described the murder scene to
reporters all over the place testimony
at Manson's trial indicated he exerted a
cult-like influence over a commune of
followers he convinced some of them to
carry out his murderous mission a
convoluted plan intended to start an
apocalyptic race war said to be inspired
by the Beatles song helter skelter
[Music]
the so-called tate-labianca murders
named after the most prominent victims
and the subsequent trial of the Manson
family became a flashpoint for social
critics of late 60s subcultures but it
was Manson's perverse charisma that most
fascinated a vietnam war weary america
what don't we understand about you just
what I said I'm inside of you man yeah I
live inside of you I'm inside every one
of you Manson died more than 46 years
after he was sentenced to be executed he
ended up serving life in prison after
California overturned the death penalty
still such a bizarre story and just
looking at Charlie's interview is creepy
to me to hear how he's talking just
totally oblivious to the harm that he's
caused very sick man yeah very much so